Welcome back to quantum computing in practice. This episode is going to focus on the first and often the most
challenging step in defining a quantum program. Mapping a general problem to a circuit that can run on a quantum
computer. This step describes how a user starting with a given computational
problem can translate it so a quantum computer can understand.
In previous lessons of this series, lessons two and three, we discussed that the mapping stage is the first step out
of four in the Qiskit patterns framework. From these lessons, you may remember that our goal was to translate
or rewrite a computational problem into a cost function or an expectation value
that we can evaluate using a quantum computer.
In lesson three, we discussed one concrete example with max cut, a problem
that is computationally hard and that is common place in combinatorial optimization.
In that example, we went through several steps to transform the initial graph into a quantum native problem. We
transformed the problem of finding the maximum number of cuts in the graph into a cost function. then rewrote that cost
function as a Hamiltonian and prepared a trial quantum state whose ground state
corresponds to the max cut. Finally, we constructed a quantum circuit representing the trial quantum state of
interest and then added the specific gates to allow the state to evolve over time. This sequence of steps is what we
call mapping. And at a high level, the procedure is general to many other applications such as quantum chemistry
and quantum simulation. Now, there's no shying away from the fact that mapping can be difficult. There isn't a
one-sizefits-all strategy for every single problem, so it can be intimidating. Today, I will highlight
some representative examples of different problems and describe how they were mapped in each case. I will quickly
recap what we learned about graph problems like those used in Max Cut and spend the rest of the lecture focusing
on how to map problems that appear in nature such as molecular structure problems in biology, electronic
structure problems in chemistry and simulation of quantum field theories in high energy physics.
But before we spend most of our time in this episode looking at example problems from the literature, I want to give you
a high-level look at the main things that we want to accomplish and consider when we're mapping a problem. There are
a few things to consider for any type of computational problem that will need to be translated into a quantum circuit.
First, you might need to simplify the problem to make it feasible. This is something commonplace to most scientific
disciplines. This is not unique to quantum computing. If you have ever heard of the expression assume a
spherical cow, it is alluding to the fact that it is often hard to describe a system exactly as it appears. But
instead, we can make reasonable simplifications that still can lead to helpful solutions.
Some examples of how we might do this in quantum computing are to limit the size or the circuit depth by choosing a
hardware efficient onzoths or truncating complex time evolutions or neglecting
Hamiltonian terms that contribute little to the final energy of a quantum state.
The next point I want to make is that you are going to have to think about writing the problem in such a way that a quantum computer can make sense of it.
Often that involves asking these three questions. One, what will our cubits
represent in this model? Two, is our problem continuous? Since quantum computers are digital, you will need to
find a way to discretise the problem. And three, lastly, does the topology of the problem align with the topology of
the hardware? If yes, that's great. But if not, we might need to implement some tricks to make it work. So let's address
this first question. What I think is at the heart of all the difficulties with understanding mapping especially as a
new concept. What can a cubit represent?
Cubits can be used to represent many things. The first and simplest in my opinion is a node on a graph. Graphs are
used to show connectivity and many different types of mathematical problems. And the nodes are a fundamental element representing a point
or entity within a network. Depending on what the whole network represents, that could be a city, a person or a
ferromagnet in a lattice. Cubits can also be used to represent bzons and firmians. Although I will caution here
that one single cubit does not exactly equal one bon or one firmian. It's a bit
trickier than that and I will go into it shortly, but in general, a chain of spins that follow some statistics is
something that can be easily translated to a cubit architecture.
Now, we're getting into examples that are a bit more complicated. For these models, it doesn't make sense anymore to
speak in terms of a single cubit.
Instead, we need groups of them to make up something physical. For example, a
group of cubits here represented on a heavy hexagonal topology can be used to represent geometrical locations of amino
acids or polymer chains. Another example is the simulation of hadron scattering
in high energy physics models which can be done by simulating the time evolution of a hydronic wave packet. In this case,
a register of cubits can be used to encode different states of a quantum field. The vacuum state of that field or
a wave packet that propagates on top of this vacuum.
Now I also want to note that mapping the problem to a quantum computer has distinct steps which are one mapping the
states onto cubits and circuits and two mapping the cost function or expectation
of the quantum observables and operators. We will see how these are handled in specific examples. But at
this point we have spoken abstractly enough about the challenge before us.
Let's look into these examples now in detail.
Let's begin with our first example. In my opinion, one of the easiest mapping problems is the one that we have already
covered in some depth, the max cut example. In that problem, the mapping was pretty easy for us because one cubit
equal one node on our graph. Using nodes on a graph is very intuitive and that is
fortunate because it corresponds to many applications. Many times when you want to model something that corresponds to a
series of nodes connected together, if the groupings are binary like zero or one or included and not included in a
set, you can simply and naturally map these nodes into bits or cubits.
In this example, and even in the one that we scaled up to 100 cubits in episode 3, the graph connectivity
already matched the topology of our superconducting hardware. So we didn't need to concern ourselves with that either. Now that's not always the case.
And if you have a more complicated or connected graph than the examples that we highlighted so far, you are going to
need to implement swap gates. But this is handled actually at the second step of kisskit patterns which is concerned
with transpolation. The other part of the max cut problem that makes it so handy is that we
already know how to express the cost function as a Hamiltonian using the cubo formulation.
Recall that in quantum computing and variational quantum algorithms, a Hamiltonian cost function is a function
that encodes the optimal solution of the problem in the ground state of the Hamiltonian.
To construct the cost Hamiltonian, we were able to use the sparse poly op class in kiskuit to specify the
connectivity of our graph and the mapping stage to the quantum operators is done. And the quantum circuit was
simply the QAOA on Zots. Now, if this isn't ringing a bell, please go back and check out episode 3 where we walk
through this in much more detail. Now, let's up the difficulty ever so slightly. Next, we are going to look
into an example modeled in the paper called resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding written by
IBM in collaboration with the University of New South Wales. A little biochemistry background. Proteins are
macroolelecules composed of long chains of amino acids. These long chains fold
in complex structures that perform a wide variety of biological functions.
Determining a protein structure in a three-dimensional space and understanding the relationships between
structure and function are among the most challenging problems in biochemistry today.
Proteins fold into useful structures due to interactions between the amino acids themselves.
As the structure twists and folds, amino acids that are far from each other on the chain might end up right next to
each other and may interact strongly. We need to get a Hamiltonian describing all of these interactions between amino
acids if we want to predict what final structure will minimize the energy. Here we will focus on amino acid chains and
how they can be modeled on a quantum computer and then how we can obtain interam amino acid distances for
calculation of the interaction energies.
With this, we actually will have gathered all the necessary contributions to the Hamiltonian in order to simulate
it on a quantum computer. In real proteins, amino acids can occupy a continuum of possible locations.
However, we are going to use a simplification here and restrict them to a lattice model where each amino acid
occupies a point on a grid. Here, the authors used a tetrahedral lattice.
Quick note here we are encoding the direction of the edges and not the nodes themselves like in the max cut problem.
Each cubit represents a possible singlestep path along the tetrahedral grid. Note that the adjacent sites have
been labeled in this diagram as A or B because of their different orientations in the lattice.
The protein chain is represented as a series of turns or directions on this
lattice. Each turn between the amino acids can be in one of four directions
corresponding to the edges of the tetrahedrin.
These four possible turns are encoded using four cubits.
This sounds a bit tricky. So let's look at this example in a little more depth.
Let's place our first amino acid chain on this point in the tetrahedral lattice. The direction to the first
amino acid chain to the second is arbitrary because the system can always just be rotated to make that edge point
in any direction we like. So let's place our second amino acid here. It's not as
easy to see, but the path from the second to the third is actually also arbitrary. All three choices would
result in having two of the edges with an angle of approximately 109.5°
between them. Picking this second edge simply determines the orientation of our protein in space. So without loss of
generality at all, we can choose the first turns to just be 0 0 1 and 0 0 1
0. With these simplifications, the configuration of the amino acid chain is simply given by this expression.
So far we have mapped the tetrahedrin edges to cubits and our quantum circuit will be an onzoth. Now we need to
consider how to encode the energy of the problem into a Hamiltonian so that its ground state gives us the optimal
folding pattern. Now for any given configuration there will be an associated energy due to the
interactions between the amino acids themselves. These interactions are strongest when the two amino acids are
close to each other. Obviously amino acids that are adjacent in the backbone of the chain will always interact with
each other. But because the protein can twist and fold, other amino acid pairs
can also interact. Amino acids 10 and 20, for example, might end up being on
adjacent sites after the protein has folded. Amino acids that end up being near each other have stronger
interactions and drive the folding process, but they do not necessarily have indices that are close to each
other. So we need a formula to describe the distance D between amino acids I and
J using the information encoded on the configuration cubits. That way we can
use their separation distance to determine how strongly they are interacting. This is a bit complicated
but bear with me because it's a neat trick. First, let's introduce a function f sub a of i that indicates whether or
not an edge a is used for the turn at amino acid i. Here a could take on any
of the four possible directions in light of the configuration coding above. We can write these functions and then we
can define a difference in the number of a labelled turns on A and B latises from
index I to index J as delta N. Why would we do this? Well, it turns out that the
tetrahedral lattice has a very useful property. Let's focus in on this amino acid here. It doesn't matter which one
it is, but let's call it the E amino acid. We want to know how far apart the j amino acid will be. And all we have
are the edges along which the backbone steps. Starting from I note that a step
out from the center along a particular edge type call it a from this a lattice
site is exactly opposite and is undone by a step out along the edge a from the
b sites. So multiple steps along edge A from any A lattice site moves the
backbone away from the E amino acid and steps along edge type A from B sites
bring you back. So the distance between two amino acids I and J along the edge
type we will label A depend on the difference between steps made along A
edges from A sites and B sites. Since A and B necessarily alternate in the
protein backbone, this is captured by the minus1 to the K term. And this argument applies to other edge types as
well. So the distance between amino acids in the tetrahedral lattice steps can be calculated in the end by this
expression. But how do we get the Hamiltonian from this long equation for the total distance between the amino acids? There
is actually a onetoone correspondence between these distances in the tetrahedral lice steps and the uklidian
distance. And you can see I calculated some of the expressions for you already.
These distances can be used in calculating the energy of your configuration.
Depending on your purpose, you might dictate a cutoff distance below which you consider the pair to be interacting
or you might do something more complicated. It may not be obvious, but we're actually done with the mapping
stage by doing this. The states of the cubits indicate the turn, and the collection of turns dictates the
distance between any pair of amino acids. Pairs of various species of amino
acids have different interactions, some attractive, some repulsive. If you are using the configuration and distance to
merely determine if known amino acids interactions are on or off, the
strengths of these are wellnown. Not by me, but you can look them up on a table here like this one. So in summary, in
this example, the cubits are used to mark locations on a lattice which together form a chain of amino acids.
And by simulating how they bend and fold, we can hopefully find better outcomes in medical research. Now, we
skipped how to calculate a few terms of this Hamiltonian because they were hyper specific to this problem. While defining
directions on a lattice can be applied more generally.
Now once you have a general Hamiltonian, you are always going to want to translate that into poly operators which
are native to the quantum computer. That's what we'll discuss next.
Let's keep going. Now let's explore how to translate a system of subatomic particles into pi operators. Subatomic
particles are broken down into two categories. Bzons and firmians. Bzons
like photons or the higs obey a certain set of statistical rules and firmians like electrons or nutrinos obey another.
The key difference between them is that bzons are allowed to occupy the same state. There's no limit to how many
bzons can be in the ground state or any other excited state. Vermians on the other hand are selfish. They demand that
every single particle has its own quantum state. Bzons also have integer spins while firmians have half integer
spins like the spin 1/2 electron or more exotic spin three half particles. To
describe a system of particles, we need a description of their energy. Let's focus on firmians. We can start with the
Hamiltonian that is written in terms of what we call C operators. These are basically mathematical objects that
correspond to creating or annihilating a firmian from a state in the system.
These are often written as fi dagger and fi and a notation that we call second
quantization. Now fi dagger is the operator that creates a firmian in the state i. Fi is
the operator that destroys a firmian in the state i. But remember quantum computers usually operate in a cubit
basis with specific rules for representing firmianic systems. They do not inherently work in the language of
fionic operators. To bridge this gap, we need to map the second quantized notation into poly operators which
naturally correspond to quantum gates.
There are several such transformations for firmians. A common choice is the Jordan wingner transformation.
The bravi kvv and parody mappings are more recent for meionic encodings.
Bzonic operations on the other hand can be transformed by using the holdstein primacov transformation or directly
mapping the fox states to a subbasis of the available bzonic modes.
And there are other options for bzons as well. Other encodings are also actively being researched. But for now, we are
going to just focus on the Jordan Wner transform.
So why don't we just assign one cubit to represent each electron? Well, we can't.
Cubits are distinguishable and electrons are not. For instance, we can easily label and identify individual cubits on
any device, but the indistinguishability of electrons means we can't label them at all. we need to actually label
instead the operators according to occupied orbitals like 1 s 2s and 2p
instead of specific electrons. Thus we need to actually label the operators according to occupied orbitals like 1 s
2s and 2p instead of labeling specific electrons. So each cubit plays
approximately the role of an orbital in the molecule which is either occupied or unoccupied.
But how we do that is actually a little bit more complicated. So now we introduce something called the Jordan Wigner mapping to keep track of
anti-ymmetry and ensure that the correct statistics of the overall firmianic system are being obeyed. The Jordan
Wingner mapping is conceptually simple because of the one:one correlation between the orbitals and cubits. There
are other mappings that accomplish a similar goal including the par mapping.
The calculation of the par of a state requires considering multiple cubits. In the par mapping and some others, the
interpretation of one cubit corresponding to one orbital does not hold.
Now let's walk through a pretty simple example together to make sure that we have the hang of this transformation.
Say we want to calculate the single cubit interaction f dagger f. We start by plugging in our definitions for the
raising and lowering operators. Then we can group terms factoring out the identity matrix i and the 1/4.
As we see, we are left with terms that will look familiar to those dealing with commutation relations. This term here in
the parenthesis is nothing but i * the commutator of x knot and y. And don't
forget about the identity that we took out.
Now remember these are just poly matrices. Thus the commutator is wellnown. The commutator of x and y in
that order is simple. It's 2 i z. Make sure not to lose track of your negative signs and you'll get this as your final
result. At the end, we have successfully rewritten a firmionic expression in
terms of poly operators that our quantum computer will be able to understand.
Let's quickly discuss how we would implement the Jordan Wingner mapping in Qiskit because although I think it's
important to understand how the mapping and similar transformations work and see it worked through at least once, you
wouldn't want to have to manually do all this workout every single time.
Especially for large-siz systems in particular, we can make use of the sparse poly op function in kiskuit to
easily create the associated poly operations from a mapping. A nonoptimal
implementation will make use of nested loops and takes about 20 lines of code.
I'll link the code here for you all to explore. But at a high level, the steps are as follows.
One, use sparse poly ops from list function to create an identity operator
corresponding to the size of the parameter space to be mapped. Two, following the definition of the creation
and unhilation operators shown previously, use sparse polyops from list function to define x, y, and z poly
operations. This will map the firmionic creation and annihilation operators to cubit spin operators encoding firmionic
occupation number into the computational basis of cubits and three generate the desired
Hamiltonian in the polybasis by applying the above operators to the orbitals of interest. This usually corresponds to
the creation of an identity matrix which represents the core the non-interacting orbitals and then applying the creation
and annihilation operators to the active space with weights that correspond to the specifics of the problem at hand. As
I mentioned, this is just a high-level breakdown. The code isn't too complicated though, and you should now
feel confident in adapting it to other problems of interest.
Now that we fully understand the Jordan Wigner mapping scheme, let's see it in action in a more complicated setup. You
might remember this paper from a previous episode as well on how drawn dynamics. I'm not going to go over the paper again in depth, but please check
out the previous episode if you missed it and you're curious. In this example, Jordan Wingner mapping is used to
express the Hamiltonian of lattice sites with L sites for the Schwinger model in the absence of an electric field. Here,
it's a lot harder to specifically pinpoint what one cubit represents in this model because it's only the
collection of cubits together that make for something physical. In this context, a wave packet. Instead, you can roughly
think of the cubits as discretized pieces of space where here L is the lattice volume in which each element or
unit cell comprises two cubits. The firmic operators that we saw in the previous slide describe the amplitude of
the wave function on a particular site.
So our Hamiltonian contains these firmionic raising and lowering operators. But to implement such a
Hamiltonian on a quantum computer, we'll need to express it in terms of spin operators, not the firmionic operators.
So we use the Jordan Wner transformation. After applying the Jordan Wner transformation, our new
Hamiltonian becomes this equation at the bottom of the slide where sigma plus is the poly operator X + I Y and sigma
minus is X - IY. Once we have a Hamiltonian written in this format, the
hard part of a mapping stage is over and it can now be easily written to a circuit in poly operators.
In summary, we have discussed four examples of how specific mapping techniques have been used lately in the
quantum computing field. Starting from the simplest and working our way up to applying the Jordan Wingner transform to
Hadron dynamics. I do realize this is a lot. This material was very technical
and if you haven't seen it before, it can be very intimidating. The good news is that I promise it gets easier and
more familiar the more time you spend practicing. And that's really the name of the game and why I named the whole
series Quantum Computing in Practice.
This isn't something anyone can just pick up and run with from the start. It requires some studying, some
headscratching, and probably some frustrating times. But I encourage you all to sit with the discomfort and
really explore the questions that arise as you continue because this is the only way to really learn. Thanks for
watching. This has been episode 5 of quantum computing in practice. Next time we are going to explore how to simulate
a Hamiltonian from scratch. We'll see you soon.